take Tribe Called Quest and mix it with
the doors that's me you can check it out
in the next issue of 400 million bucks
my money don't really feel like I do it
from the ground I build my own damn bus
people was amazed I was still a high
school
now money what about trying to get so
much that I can't keep count so you got
1 million plus Twitter followers you got
over 200 million YouTube views and
you're the first indie act in over a
decade to have a number-one album out
when did you realize like damn I made it
I still don't think I'm necessarily made
it I think I've done something awesome I
think I you know making history super
cool I think that's always that's like
very a funny term you know because it's
like the whole thing like oh you made it
like what does that mean you know CH
because I don't think I made it because
I haven't reached close to the potential
that I see myself getting to just my
whole thing as always no matter where I
get is to never be satisfied
a lot of people putting on mixtapes
these days especially you know with
YouTube and such it's a lot easier to
kind of get your content out if you can
pinpoint a couple of things you've done
to kind of differentiate yourself you
know from from the crowds of people
doing the same thing what do you think
would be I flood the internet with like
what I feel is quality content you know
like we have a lot of videos like a lot
you know we they're all creative you
know that's why I did things like giving
out a song every hundred thousand
Twitter followers because I'm just kind
of looking for ways that I can get my
fans to hear all this music without you
know trying to over saturate things and
I think it is very inspiring like kids
you know and other people who who have
dreams of doing things that that people
don't think are possible and when they
see me do something it seems more like
reachable and seems possible if they
could do it as well
your army bring your tanks become a big
boy with a big boy thing
you talked earlier about youtube and
your videos have been I think of a
pretty big driver of your success
they're really well done and they're
really wacky I mean you know where do
you get the inspiration for those videos
from I always thought I would look corny
if I was in like the type of rap video
that in the club with like girls and all
that type of stuff I don't think that I
could really pull that off my whole
thing was we always think it's more fun
and better just to go outside the box
and try and like use our videos to show
cool concepts with the Thrones like the
Frick pockmark this video it shows
something about that song that people
might not have thought about from first
but I think that's something very
important is to shoot creative videos
people compare you sometimes Eminem or I
guess I just did to the Beastie Boys it
was Khalifa what do you make of all
these comparisons and you know how does
it kind of play into going forward
people are gonna call me mm maybe
because I'm white or they're gonna call
me Wiz cuz I'm from Pittsburgh and
that's my friend but I don't really
worry about comparisons you know because
when it's all said and done you know
there will be no more comparisons I'm 19
year old kid and fairly new in this did
you ever see yourself signing with a
major record label so my whole thing is
I'm going to keep it independent because
I love working with people that I know
very well but you know if I reach a
point where there's things I can't do
which we haven't reached that point yet
but if I ever reach a point where
there's something I can't do and I need
some help from a major who knows I'm not
on like get anti major like I hate the
majors you know like I'm not that type
of person
and before we go can we get a couple
bars anything you like okay here we go
who do I love of course my mom this
interview will be available on
forbes.com okay okay yeah for good album
in stores okay thank you so much for
coming yours
they interview dujour
all right so